[Music]
relation to the second path 0.6 you who
knows that the current reaches of
interests or reckoning from the table we
received the community board receives
the current reach servant just seeking
to place
I'm assuming you've all read the
confirmation of the minutes of the 16th
of March 2020 which seems a long time
ago but if I could hit somebody maybe
the circulation but it's true and
accurate record plays sprint
any business arising from the minutes
okay moving on to item six Miri there as
well well please sort of cool and Amiri
might be it is great to see the few
weeks some buildings if you'd like to
give us an update on your Pura bass and
crappies our first of all thank you very
much for inviting us in tonight so as
you can see the Finch things all around
the building they are including the
extended site Probie so far as is the
order demolition so the guys have been
here less than about Tuesday last week
and I believe for another week and
possibly next week but basically there's
all the roofs off at the moment in the
real so basically we're here we've got
to the situation as we've we've got
enough money to do what we're doing with
just a matter of getting the building
completed and furnishing work to be done
later but the project goes for six
months so we do have six months to raise
some more money
to finish the whole job off but even if
it's not money I think we will it'll be
for intensity versus completed justice
and finishing work and so the basically
that at the moment which will sign a
contract this week and four million
dollars which is what we have to spend
which is basically four hundred and ten
from the club before done on you from
the cross huge it was quite a pure trust
and a hundred thousand dollars from this
council it would still win in the
airplane that's not but that's pretty
pivotal because obviously we're the ugly
duckling on the river we know that so
now's the chance to get out a bit
stretched well so it'll blend them with
where we are sitting there what's on the
other side of the river and or well in
the place that really will finish the
whole protocol so it's all good so we
acknowledge to the council's help got
the grant which I just mentioned but
also got some that helps for the
building consent haven't been trailing
with a Bullock and simple that absorbed
the fees for the boringest and all that
sort of stuff helps possess thousand
dollars I have to mention specifically
crusts here as well he's been great and
Simon Simon Markham well then I won't
mention names but these two guys
actually been pretty good so and sort of
status in the right to reach them so you
know head stuff for them into anyone
else along the way as well so it's um
yeah it's all good news has taken me a
long time coming you know that's done
really the the extra money we got from
the cross who do is quite appeal trust
us about the tiptoe service which means
we can we can go eat with with rebuild
so watch the space and it should be
finished before Christmas any reason you
can extend the contractors flooding
which we can but we hope not to give the
stage of the year because there's you
know Norway's prints that were makeup
which brings a powerful app which Max
and and the other one was just so good
so thinks questioners I just
congratulate you and your club and is a
mean between she was rowing means and my
family for many years I'm very excited
and I just hope somehow you can get some
more school high school students so the
day we do have to be small for in
Canterbury criteria I mean you can't
beat her in the next site leaders they
actually promote site so we put those
two things together you know we need a
swordsman to come out here and
Christian Paul some of those that
Margaret students will be leaving school
every any of them talked about Jordan
right back you know that I know but one
of the biggest problems we have been
rolling is that the kids leave school in
schools like the one you mentioned where
they probably borders and they go to
wherever they came from to start with
all my trophy agustí and that's when we
know welcome to write for us um well it
means that because we actually have
moved from here obviously the moment
with protein clubbers so that we're in
that union which I thought we're putting
on council Emma takes on the perfect a
plane and that'd be good as well so we
working within we still the bonus yeah
we'd love to get some of the rose but
historically that hasn't happen for that
reason I make something a lot of them
all stop Rory
because Rome's really is really tough
and you'll know this stuff but there are
some winter programs we try to keep them
interested
eight-point-three of grants here in a
place of Brian Thank You grant everyone
I'm grandma Claire
so look just to go through this report a
little bit of background you've probably
seen that there was respondent
circulated today this correspondence
circulated today the toilet down at
Reagan's Kate has been earmarked for
decommissioning in removals since the
toilet strategy was adopted in 2017
there has been some feedback following a
notice actually going on to the toilet
which was indicating that it was going
to be decommissioned and removed that
actually these members of the public
that want this decision really looked at
so before you we've put together a
report thanks to right and just to
outline that as well now there was also
some communication from one of the
gentlemen which I believe was was seen
today so I'm not sure if that was just
in response to the staff report that was
obviously on the agenda for today as
well because Basil's quite passionate
about rotating within the report itself
there's actually a couple of recommended
options there one is to continue with
the work to the commissioners we
currently don't have priced the
retention of the low maintenance in
terms of actual renewal maintenance done
it's because the idea has been
so only in the urinal and only in the
pen if there's on the floor
which wouldn't be the case
wasn't that the reason we addressed it
was because it just doesn't meet
sanitary conditions some years and we
identified it was one toilet in the town
CD area which didn't meet the new levels
of service which we identified for I'm
counting to little service for those two
had a number of different things which
wines mention somewhat in terms of
unisex toilets some cleaning
requirements safety requirements at the
moment there's there was a exist
consultancy did an assessment that
identified there the actual building was
okay it's not gonna fall over
however there are some entrapment issues
around the back of the toilet it's
reasonably dark and they suggested that
it's not likely that it would be safe
for people to use at night sometimes
you're in the day as well so those
safety issues identified some came to
the board with results of their tourist
jdg in the board at the time for those
reasons identified the fact that we
should demolish oh and we should
demolish it because of the cost involved
in doing a replacement or a significant
renovation to bring it to those levels
of service end because the other toilets
returning flat roofs low-end Tania's
reserve were in close proximity
the community has identified through a
number of different channels that they
would like to see it stay and Blackwell
was one of those people that have
identified that he'd like to see it stay
as well he's got people that go to the
department store I don't believe there's
a public toilet in there so outside of
hours when the library's not open the
nearest public toilet is across the road
in terms of valuables as soon as the
distances are still
okay so in because you're kind of
pulling
[Music]
the reason why the the people could use
been knowing rather than just clubs user
[Music]
Thank You military to me it falls into
the nice-to-have bracket at the moment
and we're not in nice to have space
where we need to have nice I'm sorry but
it's just 150 K defects are not very
much doubt with with the councillor
sitting around the table than regular oh
we're going to get back through even if
we want to do is not budgeted for it's a
hell of a lot of money one thing I did
could mention someone suggested paying
retail places like labels to actually
actually pay them the council actually
paid because it's a hell of a lot
cheaper than building just throw that
into the mix is a possible option as
well
say that I think signage would be very
valuable to point out that there are
toilets in the road out of Center and at
the Women's Club in once purchased stock
that'll make it seized very serious a
massive military with you've got the
signage it would serve health consider
but we had signage on the side of the
mandible bridge and also in the William
Street Bridge directing people to the
other side because we haven't got pretty
good toilets over there and it's not a
long way but the sonic receiver yo thank
you so the motion has been put the meet
next May and be a licensed I
there's against about speed limits to he
to to Ashley River and in fact it
probably covers the area from side roads
before we start the recommendations in
the in the summary are incorrect and
have you distributed so we've got the
recommendations
so this follows on from some work we did
back in September last year that made
out and consulted on a speed limit
proposal through that area we've
summarized that that consultation in the
document it would be fair to say that
there was general support for the the
changes of that we were proposing but
far from overwhelming support we also as
part of that process have consulted with
the Transport Agency and they raised
three areas of concern that we've had
some further discussion with them over
the first was the the - he we village
and our proposal had been to reduce the
speed limit unto here village from 50 to
40 and this followed on from some
discussions we've had with Runanga on
that they are very concerned about speed
through the village and we agreed to to
take their proposal
the agency has has come back and said
that in their opinion there is not
appropriate and doesn't comply with the
speed limit sitting wrong and so we have
gone back again to them and we have
reached agreement with them that that we
will investigate options to reduce the
speed limit outside the - here we scald
to 40 Kay's as either a temporary speed
limit or permanent speed limit and also
in during that process the government as
part of the road to zero strategy have
have announced a proposal to encourage
local authorities to reduce speed limits
around schools to forty caves in urban
areas and sixty caves and rural areas
we discussed that
the agency and their response was that
is not yet the rule so that may happen
at some stage in the future but it is
not yet the rule and so they are only
able to function under the rule as it
stands at the moment and so the rule
that as it stands at moments is that 50
cases the appropriate speed but we can
implement a temporary a temporary lower
speed limit at the school we also had
some discussion with the agency around
Todd's Road and they are of the opinion
that 60 canes is the safe and
appropriate speed for Todd's Road and
that is largely due to some safety
issues at the western end of toll road
and there are some out of context curbs
there there also also the opinion that
Road carriageway is quite narrow we
again we begged lament and discuss that
with them and have agreed with them that
reducing the limit to 80 K is a step in
the right direction and may not reach
everything that they desire reducing it
to 60 would require some significant
work to make that to get compliance with
that sort speed limit because it just
doesn't feel like like a 60 K
environment and so we've we've agreed
that we may need to do some work to make
it safe for ATK's and so we have agreed
that we will go away and do some work
and get some options which we will bring
into the next long-term plan discussion
and so that's the second of the three
areas where they expressed concern the
third was on Pegasus Boulevard and they
they expressed some concern about
reducing to 60 from 70 there and
suggested that we should reduce it to 50
and again we have agreed with them that
we will go bring forward a suggestion of
60 and it's also worth noting that the
when we took this to the audience if tan
board the recommendation is that they
they're suggesting that we leave it at
70 until the Transport Agency has
decided what they're doing on the state
highway so that's the recommendation to
Council is that we leave Vegas Boulevard
at 70 in the meantime until yep so that
that was our recommendation so we went
to the sorry so we're recommending going
to 60 the agency suggested 50 and we
have come reached a compromise with them
that we're recommending 50 and so we've
reached reach compromise that we are
suggesting 60 the board suggesting leave
it at 70 until such time as they the
agency was also concerned about the
unsealed roads and we had suggested
reducing them from a hundred to 80
the agency is suggesting that the safe
and appropriate speed on the unsealed
road is 16 they have also suggested that
as we go through regional speed
treatment management plan that they will
there is most likely to be a regional
speed limit on unsealed roads of 60 days
and so we have agreed with the agency to
recommend reducing unsealed roads to 16
so have exciting questions question
clarification when we recommend and thus
if we do need the roads in our own area
the other roads are we looking at all
not I mean we obviously recommend it now
a lot but its border we concentrating on
our own roads we have put them through
as a as a recommendation to to all three
boards covering the coming the whole lot
the Wrangler actually board is has only
recommended the the roads in the area
and have noted that they haven't
commented on the others and I think that
certainly if if the board has a major
concern about one of the others you
certainly welcome to to comment on it
any questions or just want to
congratulate the roadie team on the
approach to the taken here by looking at
over one big area like this I think it's
really great and so everyone's send
opportunity their input but they can see
them big context of it all which is
great and I just have a question is
there any further move from in GTA need
to have a global 80 kilometer area speed
limit on sealed
rural roads most authorities have made
them aware of the stage
this is the way to Sydney this this is a
big plus to move forward just like that
I think this is a great great move to in
the rural roads down to Haiti to
understand a lot of our rural roads and
not designed for speeds exists of that
and what a lot of people may not agree
with the approach has to be taken I
think that it will save lives I think
that's the time I think I don't agree
with it so there are many I think all of
our pieces a perfect example the road
environment is not built for that speed
people will speed on it the great
revenue collector is river odors in
regular the speed environment is not the
50k that it is in
for someone who drives around the
Christchurch streets all the time in
fact the expense when you come to the
urban areas will be will be rather
interesting I just drove down to Bishop
Street today to get there 17 so insane
40k every intersection I crossed had 40
cows on it just before the intersection
at 50 case showing that the road going
the opposite way at 450 k roads if free
Street on the way through because the
fortune not only does it cost a fortune
understand words 40 kgs down that Street
you can't do anymore
this cars parked either side of the
street and you can't get in the end of
it so the environment is built for that
many of these roads the environments are
not built for that and it just it just
makes no logical sense in which to do
that I have some sympathy with what
Barton saying about rural roads but not
all of them alike we have many rural
roads that are straight and long and in
that built for purpose you know we have
55 contracts on some of them and they
they're fine the tankers come up and
down there at ninety to a hundred gauge
themselves all the dot if you know the
week yes there are some excellence on
there sometimes and sometimes people get
seriously and sometimes people get
killed you don't want to do that they
don't drive your car because at the end
of the day you take a risk when you open
the door of the car and I don't want to
see anyone kill that's not what I'm
coming we aren't coming from but we're
just getting to the nanny state that
some people want to be
sorry I'm just letting you move a and B
what about C D they're just notes but
they're their ex lot so you happy
ABCD efg ancient icon in Madison or like
some type of this inst so this is a
another speed limit exercise and this is
asking for approval to consult on some
speed limit reviews in the area from the
river through to Cairo point so form a
North Road from the river from the
bridge through to the existing 50 K
environment or 50 K sign the south end
of cowboy and for tram road from the
main North Road intersection through to
just west of Greeks Road and there are a
couple of couple of drivers for this the
first is the the work that's happening
with the northern motorway work so the
Transport Agency is signalizing the tram
Road main or throat intersection and
they are signalizing the tram road
motorway on-ramp intersection so that
that will significantly change the
environment at that location we are also
in the process of designing
as she passed cycle wave from the tram
Road intersection through to the
southern end of of kaya point and we're
working with Hellas and designing a new
entrance way to Hellas which will
include a right turn Bay and new new bus
stop and pedestrian refuge within Mae
North Road adjacent to the hell is X's
so we looked at the at the safe and
appropriate speeds for that section of
the road and with the changes and work
that all changes environment it's
happening there 60k is has been
considered to be that the safe and
appropriate speed so weird whiskas in
consulting on reducing that the limit
from 80 to 60 now this is also
consistent with what the City Council
has done to the south so they have
reduced virtually the entire length of
that route from Preston's roads through
to the river 260 and so this section
would would add to that and then we we
came to look at the section between
Neves Road and in the southern end of
Keio point and there's a rule that
states that you need a minimum length of
800 meters for an 80 K speed limit we
just make the the 800 meters it's about
802 I think and I think that potentially
there is an argument that we should look
at pulling the the 50k and suddenly
you've come a point to the south a
little bit there is some development
there has been a resource consent that
has gone on for a development on the the
old bull farm site there that consent
has has gone quiet and the last one was
I'm not quite sure what what's happening
with that but certainly we're corn
builders are
are operating from the there at the
moment so that that makes then X is
quite a bit more significant and
certainly if if the development that
they're proposing goes ahead that would
then put some more traffic onto the that
unnamed unsealed road to the south of
the site so that would change the
environment in in that area so what
we're suggesting is a consistence
decayed from the north end of the old
bridge through to the existing 50 K
speed limit change south of quietly
there are probably arguments that can be
made either way for the agency about the
changes from
[Music]
so think of if we're looking at a at a
60 K speed limit that's probably not
appropriate on there that very obviously
bourbon section to the to the west of of
the eastern end of Briggs Road so I
think we can probably look at that in a
bit more detail but and and as a future
exercise we will be looking at the speed
limit on the remainder of tram road and
with a few probably to reducing it to 80
tram road Smith Street and Road just
before you get so you coming out of a
sixty you go to 80
then you drop back to 250 as you mean -
Christmas tree and then I hope I wrote a
little different than there but you go
past the school but they're 80 across
the bridge with the NCTA
about coming across a motorway bridge
why are they seated 89 side road is very
good example why are - like Raiders are
not beca picking number 60 through -
because you actually speed up just
doesn't make a logical seat so there's
any discussions going on these streets
or the pieces they are in the streets of
road that we are to get a big sensible
speeds
we've certainly had that discussion with
them on the on the tram Road bridge and
we do need to have that discussion on
both behind slidin Ohio I think to
ensure that that makes sense in city
we've had some informal discussions
about some of the issues on on the oka
Aafrin with turning left and those are
things and the speed will be part of
that discussion and we're going to
engage with them on those two they're
happening and going to heaven would we
not would not be sensible to do it all
at once so you're changing the whole lot
at once as opposed to one this year is
one next year when the year after a
weird would be if we could talk to them
see how the three other good ones so
these ones are being done because of
some urgency around giving us a new
speed limit in place when the new
traffic signals going so it makes sense
to have something there before they
close consultations yes it involves one
of those bridges so why would we not
involve the other two at the same time
so you could check if indeed it does
come down you've got the whole three
that are just managed that then people
are confused
cleaned up some of these streets and
here not doing any work on the
environments not there before dropping
the speedom
John John the military it just the
discussions and the in the modeling that
entity a have been doing and helping
Assessors that just work through this if
they done modeling of the effect of the
new Mon Eastern the new Eastern to drive
motorway and the effective that's going
to have been looking at that in the
sense of trying to keep people coming in
to carefully at the Hoku Road in Smith
Street intersections in other words
[Music]
won't won't they traffic on that section
of road particularly the Aires
won't it be reduced if people use the
motorway I think will be reduction but
it will still be some traffic from the
Burwood
area will still come up the road rather
than go across to the then you might
wait yeah I mean the
brilliant this is an opportunity to look
for consultation can we make an
amendment to it in terms of based on mr.
ikenson suggestion that we approve not
only looking at the change of speed to
the tram Road and the main North Road
but also include consultation for this
we need to
[Music]
[Laughter]
we should battle Thank You million to
you and just want to clarify bill my
understanding is that the speed limit on
masters Road from Preston's road to
Bethel railway line nothing this 70
philomena 60 so just recent as any other
thing I just want to wish you luck with
the consultation they're gonna be 5000
but I do know seriousness 1 this show
it's just important which I think indeed
ta you do need take a bit more
responsibility port is the speed
transmission transition coming off the
motorway I know they believe they're
quite a few knows to tell excellence on
the on the one carry rubric have been
caused by car slowing down too much as
they come off with the tram road over
bridge into the lesser extent and it's
just quite a sentence to slow down for
people and I believe that there's
something in titi ta do you need ever
breathe
consultation on just 40 we can't get the
other stuff in there makes no logical
sense to me the reasons that are given
to changing not challenging these things
we need so obviously everybody else but
tell us it's not obvious it really does
great with me I'm afraid
great nibbles just said it just seems
common sense has gone out the window
really sort of things but it's sick of
the motion thank you speak to the motion
before it's 58.4 to consider a new road
name to be added to the pre-approve row
naming lists with a copy to the
community board area the name was
supplied by the family of charlie penny
for a future subdivision thank you take
you've hit opportunity to read the
report and I would welcome any questions
perhaps thank you any questions for
Scott in seeing the nibble name register
and I raise the point whether we should
be and just doing another advertisement
to get it up to the community to ask I
don't know whether we do it or not but
it's probably one of those things we
should do once a year and ask people
they like till three are wondering if
something had gone out
to achieve if we meet a oh sorry yep
moving on to a 2.5 in just beard mind
we're concentrating on right yeah so we
are looking at a brutally existing right
name Silverstream I'm about to write
number three and probably new row names
we created Stage five or silver stream
development in this country most in
cowboy named we part of the further
development which we've some part of the
lime lime living Tom advised me however
the two to three certificate will be
provide for by the end of this week it's
not really next week so these some who
didn't see around having these names
approved so you have take it you also
had the opportunity to read this report
is presented and I look forward to have
any questions you may have in
Christianson three middle tier expressed
my concern about this report coming back
with just looking at a very small
section of the subdivision and there are
some implications around it which I
think we need to be very mindful of
firstly while I don't have a problem
with names Austrian Boulevard we do need
to realize that if it continues on down
the risks of the road towards the east
it will mean they're elderly terrace
ends up being broken up into two parts
in will obviously need to go through
to the two to two
[Music]
anybody wants fake I guess if they plan
for two to four and then it gets proved
then they'll be moving towards title and
it stay so they have to have the war to
have a physician with properly addresses
and numbering and stuff like that so the
street names have to be in place but
time that they go for title they said oh
my other and my job is to do
subdivisions and Road numbering so
they're one after basically it comes
Road naming subversion Road numbering
title people buy property and then
they've got addresses as well to that so
yeah I don't know if fully full timing
of it but I think they're burning a bit
of a hurry to push it through I guess to
also for the marketing side of things
for the new line living we're trying to
could not actually being part of a
competes rather than out its Road they
concentrate more on local I did see an
area just to sort of move things forward
with names I mean the reason I put penny
was just for that reason but I'd like to
hear
Martin's reasons as to why those
particular names and if anybody else did
anything in the particular reason
because I think that's the important
part
around Silverstream what's the reason
for putting on the year-end and
the reason I put the name up who happily
forward is that's the traditional name
for this area and I'm really concerned
then we were going to end up going to
the end of the subdivision then we hit
actually named any rate in this area and
the other option which was Waverly was I
understand this was the name of a
traditional lane over in this area and
it's the whole team of the road Navy
processes that have come before us is
where the flannel siding was on the
corner of Christmas Road it takes and
quite quite a catchment doesn't go into
well I appreciate that
it may be able to be used nice to take
it in the future its Waverly is a little
bit like if you don't mind me saying
we had a silly would have to ask for
those people I think we could use that
name though there are new people in me
and it was one when I was involved it
could ruin the Pegasus and so on
an existing property owner wished his
name to be held back until he died use
it in the future don't mind that it's on
his ready now and he wants to
remain there isn't his own identity and
it can be used on the futures of some
here but I could be the same thing
I don't thank you great thank you madam
chief my concern was with regard to the
main line was developments lime real
estate I then felt that potentially this
could set a prison in terms of do we
have a higher courts Lane do we have a
rain white Avenue and late service stuff
and that was my consumers utilizing lime
Avenue and why we've already got a whole
list of names why don't we utilize those
as opposed to
No
[Music]
thank you so many years ago
we had quite a conversation we were
ending up with a whole lot of streets
that went the street names brings that
to us the discussion was over the same
developer as this developer and I note
that he still to this day hasn't
actually put any names on the list and
he have come to us with these names have
put them on the list for the reasons
that he was listening then maybe we
could have picked some of that his names
that were wrong the list but I mean the
list is the list and the board is that
the government's over these street names
and I personally think that the two
names that are the I had some sympathy
with the first name of course that had
mentioned I also take note of what he's
saying about Ed Lee tears in the future
as well we need to make sure that we've
got allowances for that at the time but
we must I think we must remove this
important part of history that these are
characters of our town in many ways in
the names of our town and there's a book
available to he's written and I
personally want to see that continue and
make sure that we use these list names
and people wish to add to them more than
welcome as mr. Feeny just as we get a
report back sooner rather than later
regarding the other road mains in this
area so we can deal with those well in
advance rather than when the developers
already submitted this to d3 application
you'll be provided to the developers
when I seen my own contact with him and
saying either listen he's their policy
for roaming and also here's a list of
road names which you can choose from its
consultation with them in the day I mean
they guess it's up to them to whether or
not I go down that road so yeah I think
the names that have got some history in
the proper streets I think for this
particular case is actually true roads
it could be with other completes that
could be named Meggy way in line has
been moved
[Music]
we have another 8.6 we've got two
applications either will do perhaps
these are two good applications that I
think is worthy of consideration I went
it take the subject in here you remind
the board that you've got $1,600 in your
grant fund this is the end of the
financial year and members are free to
actually give them any amount that you
miss fields I want you that the $500 is
just a guide so if you feel like this is
influentially and you don't want to
carry the money over you're more than
welcome to give them more money if you
so wish
usually we have asked the finance
department to actually verify this in
light of carbon 19 in the budget if it's
going to be carried over we haven't
heard back from them but it usually the
last two years it did get carried over
we have somebody that would like to move
or make us gesture on a B or C you move
a and B so they've asked for a thousand
five hundred do we have a seconder for
their thank you madam chair
I know diddly diddly Chris Lee she's she
runs very good austere programs at
school and if she's providing service to
the community she organized she's
standing on D and we have somebody
approve a grant
about $500 to the Caraga my early
learning since moved by Jackie secret
into place John you wish to speak to the
system already so they're asking I'm
just not sure
thank you ma'am the only addition I
would like to see in this application
would be that the money all those in
favor please
[Music]
thank you madam chair I will take the
reporters read this is just for the
ratification of the port submission on
the council's annual plan
[Music]
let's pick that out print something else
somebody see can they please I need to
speak to keep business report well
actually I've enjoyed the same meetings
I hate the Whig reason why McCreery
exists group we had a really good
meeting the other day
[Music]
clients of the down declare over the
last six weeks seven weeks which has
been really neat was happening the
elderly people and you all to be the
cowboy the sexy we're not having the
kids that she ever takes break covert
sort of put the kibosh on met but we are
encouraging staff in schools dominating
the Year celebrations but we are going
in between sorry
number twelve members change strategy
the car politics phone was cancelled so
Martin cook rang me about organizing a
virtual and so it's sort of a
collaboration between the wiry arts
we've got 50 artists or nearly 50 and
it's been advertised widely he's doing
all that so it's fantastic
so I think it's just keeping the name of
car boy out there
we've had a few from outside the
district that we've allowed and we've
had some new artists come in and each of
them have after five we've sold some I'm
sure we won't sell anywhere near the
sort of numbers that we sell and then
last Sunday Saturday morning a group of
from Christchurch they regularly
organized by he takes tours of groups of
about 20 to 30 or 20 people round
galleries in Christchurch and so anyway
the week before to ask if people come
out out on the key so I had great
delight and he wanted me to tell them
all about art
and I'm sure they will all come back now
that they've seen it so many of them
said to me they haven't been out here
oldest update she was here there was for
immediate and for immediate steps
funding applications and the most
significant one for $26,000 of total
project price of nine thousand was the
old and as to it ends there and eight
and a half hectares and total
restoration and weed control
thousand dollars out of the immediate
state fund so this there were there were
several others applications Springvale
there were those at my way you just over
the cast and him and wetland is
somewhere country but this is a the most
significant one and it's actually in our
page so the before Oh between so that's
to deal with them to deal with willow
and we control and restoration quite
nicely so that was yes there was also a
presentation which we've had to water to
land and water as well from he can he
can as you know applied Growth Fund for
the money the multi millions that are
have an environmental outcome they've
applied for seventy two million over
five years creating a hundred and eighty
six jobs they haven't heard yet but they
expect to hear in the next week or so
weeks and some of our projects including
there was also I think when we were
having water party last week on Tuesday
apply for more provincial Growth Fund
money you've got three days to get your
application again the government has
money and I think your people working
extremely hard to get projects
and I presume getting them and got them
and got the man that's seen seven in for
the community facility fund funding
application so that already two weeks
lots so we contacted them and they see
that from the Sophie rapidly working to
frame up her own implications to see if
we can get our own they're all targeted
for creating jobs but the opportunity
for doing like it's it's fits in
planting and that sort of stuff where
there are bodies on the ground out there
doing stuff oh yeah we it'll be
interesting to see how successful we are
and the other thing that land and water
committee the Kim River subcommittee in
the Copper River rehabilitation
subcommittee has now come formerly under
their committee and we've also heard at
our he's set up a working group of staff
me another counselor and we actually and
moved to invite she of water zone which
is Michael Blackwell and also another
chair of Reuben to be part of the group
from that we would like to get stuff
probably two years since we put on the
that the council put in the applications
maintenance of my own work Stewie kid
god yes that taken and we haven't got to
eat they wanted various other things and
I won't saw this in the service still
working on it that means the money that
we've got on the king and we've got 195
k allocated most of it for significant
stuff we actually been able to do it and
it's just sitting there
of course it's getting a bit of interest
but sitting there waiting for this he
can concede I'm just looking on second
tired of this I'm going to we say we
need to well I know it's gone through
the process we've had to do a drainage
maintenance review that's coming back to
utilities in writing and then it goes
back to he can fully bus we might be
able to actually do some of this work
but there's quite a little just to
refresh your memory is about we've got
195 k for rehabilitation we've got 100 K
in our heart our we've got through the
total going into rehabilitation plant
that sort of work from this council
alone well you're doing well any
questions
sorry we weekly so when we get the
Meccan and as you're with some a hearty
tower is mapping of all the public land
alongside our waterways
there are hundreds that he deserves us
that you wouldn't know about when we've
got it to a point I've seen it and just
a draft presentation and was only the
first cut of it not too far away I think
it's really valuable that it we come
back and present it to the council into
the community board because you'll be a
standard for cycleways all over the
place xho is the council rip on the well
being North Canterbury board you know
this code 19 has had this significant
effect on our community and we've seen a
huge increase in demand for for social
services and I don't think it opens of
job losses then impact on families so
yeah it's a couple of months a huge
surge in demand those services also the
council upon kPa and we've been working
with a couple of media companies on
campaign for card base for out the the
coop agenda which you may appear on the
radio already but the consensus is there
the next couple of months we're gonna be
really catch-up mode people are really
busy at the moment
but it's probably really going to be
September October that's gonna be a real
crunch particularly for the businesses
in the town and we'll get a bit of
picture of what the impact may be we're
all keeping their fingers crossed of
course that North Canterbury is going to
be a little bit of new to some of the
national trends that are you see
occurring but we want to be really and
be able to deal
hello thank you madam chair I'm the
anonymous member down on the corner it
seems a while since we last meet during
that period the councillors meet I serve
on a regular basis we've had the annual
clean deliberations the annual clean
recommendation to do to be proved
tomorrow illuminance at the council
meeting tomorrow
the council has approved that 19
recovery clean before so I think
experiences of the youth ranks have
proved the useful template if you like
for what the council are looking at
doing going forward and that will
involve a number of community
stakeholders with the council providing
support I attended a local government
New Zealand webinar was present as well
I didn't really learn anything because
they were presenting that was regarding
how to deal with they Co vat19 impact on
community finances and I'm pleased to
say that the council staff reports to
consider I've just mentioned there is
another free webinar coming up it's a
neat ETA one called the road to zero and
so I'm going to find it's free if any
members are interested
I'm also the chair of creative
communities which is a grant allocation
committee for the art jakey as a member
of their group we've made a number of
grants
unfortunately the coop way out here so
application if I understand that the ice
sculpture one which was an explication
by Glen course that's still on the table
but Prince may the funding was approved
for it
we were just weren't sure if it was
going to happen or not but we approve
the grant my portfolio is regulation and
civil defense in those areas have been
quite busy
that includes building civil defeats the
operation center was activated lasted
for about four weeks welfare team early
sister died food being some supermarkets
with food delivery and like camping
ground in freedom campers
a local primary school also carried out
a suit I have parents in 50% of the
appearance responding and they had a
very good to now see that sorry not
fifty percent fifty percent of those who
responded and they did I - now see that
their family had been impacted either by
redundancy wage or that was possibly
coming in to level three have locked
them so I think
I noticed both weights at the moment so
it's not an easy area what else
lime loving silver stream last week it
was Sun Tzu's and whether to be going to
a hearing or not at that point was
looking at going to a race course
Council at the board area that origin
seat it's an interesting proposal to
other was source content hearings
deferred or postponed during so whilst
the council was locked down as far as
possible that he's being business as
usual
faced itself then so anyhow that's
probably enough for me so thank you very
much you would have heard from your
chair that the young Texas meeting
extremely successful and negative there
were some negative statements coming out
the challenges that we've got you know
some people on the other side of it you
will you will within this district gonna
be push just a little be the way an
extra mile that week brilliant job you
know the stories out there of people
having to wait some of the opposition
places around the district for a week
ten days to get the order that couldn't
where the new world headed in most cases
the same day she's going to go to the
otherwise my mind time table
thank you thank you John brilliant I
asked earlier in the year with regard to
the courtesy walkways and it was turned
down understanding what a question
however I come back or any feedback from
that so I've now asked further standing
or the question with regard to that
because a lot of residents are still
concerned about the courtesy walkways a
month ago I was asked to attend food and
budgeting meetings and that was in my
role as the food forest chair and from
that we'll be looking at developing food
security communities plan that relates
to again funding that the government are
actually putting out like councillor
Redmond attended a system assisting
communities in meeting and I agree with
you complete waste of time but never
mind I've also attended many North can
be neighborhood support meetings and
following on from councillor Redmond the
families that are in need with regard to
their actually never being supported
every Thursday by a local school
twenty-one families are getting food
boxes each week tomorrow we get our
first schools returning to the carpool
food forest and today we were accepted
by the children's University the
children's University is effectively a
it's being run by the Lincoln University
where they've got outdoor education
facilities that they've all linked
together and I've asked the client with
food for us to be part of it
and so we're now part of this huge
outdoor education facilities and we
should have schools and community groups
coming from all over Canada just to
visit the Kabu food forest following on
from that we've got the Canterbury
University coming on Wednesday
we've got run with teachers coming on
Wednesday as well so it's amazing as to
how many people are now coming from out
of the district during isolation every
Friday we would normally have
food deliveries to the food forest and
we would freak between 40 to 50 families
every Friday
but during isolation level 4 we were
unable to do that so we surely and I
delivered the food boxes directly to the
families and just to give you an idea
and its really follows on from Martin I
don't believe that we haven't seen the
worst of this yet we were delivering up
to 94 families food boxes each week 18
of those were connected to our I would
also just like to mention to people
Kevin and Kim I don't even know their
last names but they were delivering food
to the food forest every few days they
clicked it from a local supermarket and
deliver it into the food forest and I've
been doing it for four or five years
from what I can understand and they
couldn't deliver it to directly to the
families so they're dropping it off the
food forest so people could come and
click the food directly thinking
counselor Blakey with regard to the
swingbridge which i believe is going to
be running pretty quickly I've asked a
question about Porter's place frame
that's going to be cleaned up there's a
new bike shop now open in the Hoka road
there's a new finisher shop on Charles
Street badillo's has now taken over jigs
and we've also got the questions
answered with regards the grey water
dump station which I still believe the
design doesn't really fit with and the
team will give that sorted in time
following on from the carpod jingle I
spoke with GPS and car TVNZ we're
running a promoter of Township so we've
used the cardboard jingle and we've used
a video and put that untruth and to
enter TVNZ so let's hope we get some
promotion for cardboard and just just a
couple more things chief had a lot of
phone calls from local residents with
regard to concerns about the well there
is a position in by residents that it's
a foregone conclusion
and it's certainly not but there's been
a lot of phone calls to and from us in
relation to that with direct roading
have had another phone calls from meadow
Street residents and also Hilton Street
residents with both with regard to
driving issues and speeding down those
two roads
thank you madam chief if you don't well
bit of everything really
Kazu meeting after zoom meeting zoomed
in man am i pleased that areas there is
disappeared while yonder for a while
seems like fun when you start it's it's
rather interesting
we got the Mojito committee tomorrow
first time it's me it was due to me just
before covert so that thing thing back
up and running
of course it's just starting to roll one
of the issues around that of course is
that legislation even under covert
didn't allow for people whose licenses
run out over code which is a bit
interesting so we've challenged there
and see here we go spec into selling
about there and what they're doing so if
you do because the license hasn't been
renewed or they have to apply for a new
one is actually not a damn thing we can
do it to you see the legislation so and
then legislation in May didn't if need a
warrant or its trafficker didn't work
for licensing so just in case they come
up those issues you may be confronted by
someone whose Aberdeen was doing we can
deal with
Julie as we go along we are possible to
the road maintenance contracts out for
the council so that's a look at those
things
the clean air plane came to us the other
day on the clean air pen looks like
we'll be the only council actually
submitting to the clean air plan that's
out so it's rather interesting but
something this board I want to have a
quick look at I think it's it's close so
you may not have time can I encourage
you to at least have a bit of a look
have a hypno is here and we've got the
water bodies the new water that the
government's looking at the three waters
we like every other local body in the
country really have no idea what's going
on trying to so we can work together but
some type of dia and we're trying at
least to get off we press we sit pretty
good in that space but often some people
who said pretty good are the ones they
have the most the pack and ride is still
worth it still is going along at pace
some success I understand with leak in
on the misunderstanding about the
consultation on net the mirrors dumps
will work on that in these so I think
it's the first six months of the year as
the
putting in the new bus routes and
although the greater crisis Kravis if we
the other day we're doing and even
though they were just the other thing
that we to the growing some leagues
seats and that sort of thing through
there the changing rooms are underway as
you've seen the softball diamonds are
underway the
last week on the proposal
[Music]
I did you say
we've been on 17 I might leave this one
to members forum later on but we need
the recommendation anyway somebody made
the recommendation a Oh second do you
with two sets of standing order
questions tabled please if the members
could also just move that it would be
highly appreciate your Monday the 20th
July 2020
[Music]
you